and ladies and gentlemen
let's show our appreciation for these
great american heroes
representing all the families here today
colonel chris whalen
thank you colonel for will crow looking
for his fourth win of the year
should surpass 100 pitches
in tonight's game ready to go here's the
one two and a swing of the miss struck
him out with a tight slider down in the
way one out juan soto
oh that's a dandy
struck him out looking with that dendy
tonight against a right-hander
23-year-old josiah gray so it's his
eighth start as annette and his ninth
overall three two pitch outside and he
walked him well he hung in there long
enough
takes the walk
here's the set of the pitch swinging a
drive head well the left center field
thomas in the run to his right makes a
running catch up near second was the two
goal hustling his way back to first to
the throw comes in to kibum near second
base
he holds off and gets the base on balls
first base runner is the pitcher
and it's popped up perez
[Applause]
final out
continues
all four
here comes
and a swing and a miss on a slider in
the dirt picked up by ruiz who put the
tag on him to complete the strikeout
so that is the first strikeout for
josiah gray
here's the 3-1
and now it's down and then
it's another walk so the bases are
loaded on walks
you see career numbers with the bases
loaded
for
grannies
and into right center field of base hit
one run in tsutsugo waved
and he will be
out he did not touch the plate even
though the ball was dropped by release
did he get a lane did he have a lane to
slide they're going to challenge it the
posey roll that's what they're going to
ask did the ball take ruiz into his path
or was he set up the pirates get the
call
swing and a miss on the breaking ball
back door
pumping strikes and up the middle it
goes
a base runner for soto to start the
fourth a guy on board
who wants soto has driven in 30 times or
so this year
there's a fastball ripped into right
escobar is going to make the turn and
stop
[Applause]
[Music]
back-to-back strikeouts
wow that's uh something else
base has loaded nobody out here's
cambridge ruiz
and he'll golf one into right center
this might clear the bases escobar and
soto home
here comes bell
standing up ball down barrels it up
[Applause]
little missile in the gap clears the
bases three to two nets good swing
breaking ball off the end of the bat and
that ends up going a pretty good ways
out to right center
he's thinking three until they stop him
and reynolds will
and there you go a baker's dozen
13 straight games for thomas aborters
the set by banda check of the runner
thomas 3-2 pitch swung on line to left
center field toward the gap this one is
down and rolling toward the bullpens and
left center rounding third is thomas
still coming to score pulling into
second with a double as al cd's escobar
this is not a bad pitch but he goes down
and beats a good pitch
for a double and an rbi so back-to-back
doubles here in the fifth
soto hit that ground ball through the
right side of the infield last inning
on a pitch up he's two for three he's
now driven in 83 and the nets
lead by three
112 on the juan soto bait look at that
classic juan soto swing
two-strike approach back legum
lower half incorporated
[Music]
ryan reynolds
drives one deep to right center field
anchor down and clear the deck
and that was a bullet 110 miles per hour
center cut
95 in 110 out
here's the 2-0 to ben gamel is swinging
a high fly ball to right this one is
deep and this one is gone
talked about the home runs now he gamble
didn't get it like reynolds got it but
they count the same
just 92 miles per hour went 347 feet but
it knocks things up
how about that
back to back walks
here's tsugo's walk three times tonight
up and away you get ahead in the count
and you can get guys out on a pitch off
the box a bit two down
now it's bryan reynolds
adam sets up right down the middle
ball four he walks in a run and the
pirates lead it
tonight here's the pitch swinging a weak
tamper toward the mound machado can't
get it and moran's gonna beat it out for
an infield hit and an rbi the pirates
lead it seven to five
a bell went to the back
and so when machado couldn't get it
there was nobody there
ball just kind of
rolled to a stop
infield single and a run batted in the
first pirates hit of the inning
ground ball right side and out and
shallow right it's dropped
garcia throws toward third everybody's
safe
out in shallow right booted
gamble hustling of course
e4
9-5 inning continues
[Applause]
soto is coming up
got a pair of singles in three at bats
the pitch
hard shot up the middle and a base into
center field right over the second base
bag and so it's a three-hit game for
juan soto
he'll drive that ball the other way with
authority for a base hit
waved around third is soto and here come
the nets it's nine to six
[Applause]
a ball club
there's a swing in a hard liner past the
backhanded triumph kibum at third and
into left field around second park he
touches third joey cora waving him home
escobar's relay from short left he's in
there
newman scrambles to third and the
pirates lead it 10-6 on newman's
hit and an rbi rbi for newman infield in
and
a fair ball
wait a minute the catcher must have
picked it up or tried to and now he
throws out newman
what
i think as he went to pick it up and tag
hayes it just popped out of the out of
his hand
i mean that's what i think i saw turned
out to be a heck of a play to get the
out at home
yeah watch as he comes up yeah wow comes
up the tag of it just kicks out of his
glasses he looks at his glove doesn't
know where it is
here's mr national himself
ryan zimmerman
[Music]
zimmerman a loud sound to straight away
center
see
you
later
ryan zimmerman's second pitch homer of
the year and his 13th
the nets may not be done just yet
they won their fifth game when trailing
after eight
and the tapper to the right side
and on to first and raise the jolly
roger it's another comeback